[音楽]
ています
持ったん
夢のようなパワー圧倒的な美貌得て活躍
するそんな魔法のような世界に憧れたこと
ありませんか
持った
ん
メタバースという言葉を知ってますか
このメタバースこそが今お話したような夢
を叶えてくれる空間です
次世代のインターネットとも呼ばれてい
ます
メタバースの概念は複数ありますが主には
現実とデジタルの世界をつなく仮想空間の
ことだと言われています
さらにその空間に複数の人々か同人ログ
インし
会話や触れ合いをしながらあらゆる社会
活動が行われるそのような状態そのものを
メタバースと呼びます
こんなことを言うと sf 映画のような
未来的なライフスタイルを創造されるかと
思いますが
そうでありません
メタバースはすでに存在しています
実際にその仮想空間では多くの人間ドラマ
が生まれています
一大事業とも呼べるようなプロジェクトも
立ち上がっています
今日をお伝えしたいのはメタバースによっ
て難しいとされる社会の課題解決等も可能
にして大きなメリットを得られたという
実例をあげたいと思います
ん
バーチャルマーケットというデジタル空間
量のイベントがあります
ん
このイベントには世界中から100万人
以上の人たちが開催のたびに訪れています
これは単なる動画の視聴数などではあり
ません
来場者はその空間に平均3時間も滞在して
いますまた個人商店から
な種あるクライアントレベルの大企業の
ものまで1000件以上チョップが
てをを連ねています
また誰もが知る有名ゲームやアニメ映画の
キャラクターがあなたを待っています
雷業者はこのイベントに友達と一緒に遊び
に行くことができます
ショッピングモールのような場所や
アトラクションを楽しむこともできます
平面の ec サイトに誰かと一緒に
出かけることはできませんよね
バーチャル空間でなら可能
ヘッドセット頭
ぽつ入荷にしたりまるでデジタル空間自分
がいるようなリアリティ
テーマパークで遊んが思い出に匹敵する
ようなそんな体験を得られるのです
これ実はもう3年以上前から展開されてい
ます
メタバースの一大事業であり
分からです
デジタルで作品が作れる
店をもって売買する
自動車も試乗体験なんかもあります
アパレルの接客も
ジェットコースターのような
アトラクションまで様々なサービスが提供
されています
このようにデジタル空間量で同時に多数の
人がそんなリ働いたりする
そこに経済圏がありメタバースを呼ばれる
世界が実在しています
お伝えしたように参加している人々も大変
多いです
そして増え続けています
まるでこれから作られるような
世界として語られるメタバースという言葉
は古くは剽窃スノークラッシュ内での
ネーミングでした
ただ著名人がリスペクトから例えたで
あろう人ことによってピッチに公用語の
ように広がりました
ここで何度も言いますがメタバースは
すでにある世界なのです
バーチャル空間上では日々さまざまなこと
が起こっています
100万人規模でのサービスだけではなく
数え切れないほどのアイデアが仮想空間に
構築されていってます
爪ともいえるものが毎日生まれているん
です
ほとんどの人はメタバースや vr ar
という言葉を知っていても
この空間内で起こっていることのほとんど
を知ることはありません
私たちが普段利用しているメディアなどが
vr 空間料理まだ存在していないから
でしょうか
便利な検索サービスらーまだありません
バーチャルからリアル a の両方だけが
まだかなり分断されている状態と言えば
正しいかもしれません
そんなメタバース空間での特別な事例を
紹介します
遊びやビジネスだけではなく
持続可能な社会にながるような
具体的な事例としての紹介です東京の守備
はが数年前にバーチャル化されました
その中のファッションビルで
ハンデキャップ1人が定員となって現実
世界の人を接客しました
彼女は足が悪く
現実世界ではペットから起き上がること
すらできません
昔からファッションブランド働くことを夢
に見ていましたが現実が変わりそうにない
そう言って諦めていました
でもそれがバーチャル空間であればかなど
です
アバという仮想空間を動き回るための体を
使えば自分の理想の姿で走り回ることが
できます
この vr の力を使って彼女はい目立っ
たファッションブランド店員として働く
ことを実現しました
現実の世界の渋谷にいる人々を接客して
もちろんしっかりとしたお給料を得ること
ができました
夢が叶ったのです
もうちょっとの事例としてバーチャル
マーケットの主催者でもあるフィオという
人物は
もともと者会議員として活動していました
ある日重度のうつ病を患ってしまいいい
人と会うことすら全くできなくなって
しまいました
妻子がありながら数年間も働けない状態で
大変悩んでいましたん
そんな中
vr 2 de 8 e
刑事たら空間情念をコミュニケーションで
あれば問題なく活動することができる
そこに希望を見出したのです
仮想空間の中であれば生きていける
でも当時そこには経済店などなかったん
です
生きるにはそれを作るしかないと考え
生まれたがバーチャルマーケットです
驚きの集客力を持ち個人から国際的な企業
もこぞって参加するような一大事業を
生み出しました
現実には誰にも会わずに仮想空間上での
コミュニケーション頼りに
see you とも呼べる仲間に出会い
いまでは多くの人に求められる事業を超え
たマーケットを作り上げたのです
これは多くの人々にとってメリットになる
ような
メタバースでどういう可能性を秘められて
いるかが分かる事例になるのではない
でしょうか
ビジネスで言うならば
まさに
ブルー王者
夢のある世界です
そういった塩かもしれません
いまご荘櫂した事例のようにメタバースは
さまざまなメリットをもたらしてくれます
社会的な課題を解決することすらもできる
と私は信じています
これからメタバースは一般的なものになる
でしょ
ただしそれは世界の常識というのを彼らは
ちょっとかけ離れているいうかもしれませ
ん
お伝えしてきたようにチャンスが持ちそこ
にあると感じられるならばいち早く今の
常識を自ら変えていく必要があります
人類はこれまで何度も常識を更新して進化
してきたと思いますそれを少し早めるだけ
なのでそれほど大変なことじゃないと思い
ます
今日この話を通して伝えたかったことが
あります
常識とは過去に誰かが作ったものだという
こと
不登校疑問に感じることがあったとしても
なんとなく凝縮だからといって考えること
を止めたことありません
僕はあります
でそれをそのままにせずに行為に出して
届けてみましょう
それを続けてみましょう
常識というものは声を上げた人を中心に
回りの力が変わって再定義されて最適化さ
れて感じです
そうして新常識を守ってくれる世界からは
ああこれまで思いもよらなかった存在
メタバースでの一大事業整理させる人が
現れて出会えるかもしれません
自分がそうなるかもしれません
メタバースの中で
凡人がはい天才に交渉化するかもしれませ
ん
ただ僕自身は特別は才能がなくてあの一般
の人間です
でもたくさんの才能たちに出会えてきまし
た
その結果
バーチャルマーケットの運営する会社の
代表
やらせてもらってます
そうした機会に恵まれたであろう
唯一の行動は
先ほど申し上げた常識を捨て去ることを
日常的にやっていたからです
僕だが凡人でもできるんですから
難しくないと思います
気持ちの問題がだと思いますねそれをやる
ことによってたくさんの人にたくさんの
メリットに出会えるのであればむしろ
どんどんやるべきだと思うんです
そしてこのメタバースに可能性を感じる人
が少しでもこのトークで
いたならばぜひ一緒にその世界を広げて
いけるように
なれば嬉しく思います